do you think in order to solve
intelligence
or to do to replace the lex bot that
does interviews as we started this
conversation with do you think
the system needs to be
sentient do you think he needs to
achieve something
like consciousness and do you think
about what consciousness is in the human
mind
that could be instructive for creating
ai systems
yeah
honestly i think probably not
to to the degree of intelligence that
there's
this brain that
can learn can be extremely useful can
challenge you can teach you
um converse you can teach
it to do things i'm not sure it's
necessary personally speaking
but
if consciousness or any other biological
or evolutionary
lesson
can be
repurposed to
then influence our next set of
algorithms that is a great that is a
great way to actually make progress
right and the same way i try to explain
transformers a bit how it feels we
operate when we look at text
specifically
these insights
are very important right so there's a
distinction between
um
details of how the brain might be doing
computation um i think
my understanding is sure there's neurons
and there's some resemblance to neural
networks but we don't quite understand
enough of the brain in detail right to
to be able to replicate it but then
more
if you if you zoom out a bit how we then
our thought process how memory works um
maybe even how evolution got us here
what's exploration exploitation like all
the how these things happen i think this
clearly can inform algorithmic level
research and i've seen some examples
of these being quite useful to then
guide the research even it might be for
the wrong reasons right so i think
um
biology and what we know about ourselves
can help a
whole lot to build um essentially like
what we call agi this this general um
the real gato right the the last step of
the chain hopefully but
but consciousness in particular i don't
i don't myself at least think too hard
about
how to add that to to the system but
maybe maybe my understanding is also
very personal about what it means right
i think this even even that in itself is
a long debate that i know people uh
people have often um
and maybe i should learn more about this
yeah and i personally
i notice the magic often on a personal
level especially with physical systems
like robots i have a lot of
uh
legged robots now in austin that i play
with and even when you program them when
they do things you didn't expect
there's an immediate
anthropomorphization
and you notice the magic and you start
to think about things like sanctions
that has to do more with effective
communication and less with any of these
kind of dramatic things
it um
it seems like a useful part of
communication
having the perception
of consciousness
seems like useful for us humans we we
treat each other more seriously we are
able to uh do a nearest neighbor
shoving of that entity into your memory
correctly all that kind of stuff seems
useful at least to fake it even if you
never make it so maybe like yeah
mirroring the question
and since you talk to a few people do
you then you do think that
we'll need to figure something out
in order to achieve
intelligence in a grander sense of the
world yeah i i personally believe yes
but i don't even think it'll be like a
separate island we'll have to travel to
i think it will emerge very quite
naturally okay that's easier than
us then thank you but the reason i think
it's important to think about is you
will start i believe like with this
google engineer you'll start seeing this
a lot more especially when you have ai
systems that are actually interacting
with human beings that don't have an
engineering background
and we have to prepare for that
because there will be i do believe there
will be a civil rights movement for
robots as silly as as it is to say
there's going to be a large number of
people that realize there's these
intelligent entities with with whom i
have a deep relationship and i don't
want to lose them they've come to be a
part of my life and they mean a lot they
have a name they have a story they have
a memory and we start to ask questions
about ourselves well
what uh this thing sure seems like it's
capable of suffering
because it tells all these stories of
suffering it doesn't want to die and all
those kinds of things and we have to
start to ask ourselves questions what is
the difference between a human being in
this thing and wait so when you engineer
i believe
from an engineering perspective like a
deep mind or anybody that builds systems
there might be laws in the future where
you're not allowed to engineer systems
with uh displays of sentience
unless
they're
explicitly designed to be that unless
it's a pet so if you're if you have a
system that's just doing customer
support
you're legally not allowed to display
sentience we'll start to like ask
ourselves that question
and then so that that's that's going to
be part of the software engineering
process do we do we which features do we
have in one of them as
communications sentience but it's
important to start thinking about that
stuff especially how much it captivates
public attention
yeah absolutely absolutely it's a it's
definitely a topic that
is important we
think about and i think in a way i i
always see not not i mean not not every
movie is is is equally
on point with certain things but
certainly science fiction in this sense
at least has prepared society to to
start thinking about certain topics that
even if it's too early to talk about as
long as we are like reasonable um it's
certainly gonna prepare us for for both
um the research to come and how to i
mean there's many important challenges
and and topics that um come with with
building an intelligent system many of
which you just mentioned right so
i think
being we're never going to be
fully ready unless we talk about this
and we start also
as i said just kind of expanding
the
the
the people we talk to to not include
only our our own researchers and so on
and in fact places like deepmind but
elsewhere
there's more interdisciplinary
groups forming up to start asking and
really working with us on these
questions um because obviously this is
not initially what your passion is when
you do your phd but certainly it is
coming right so it's it's fascinating
kind of it's it's the the thing that
brings me to
one of my passions that is learning so
the in this sense this is kind of a new
area that
as a learning system myself i want to
keep exploring and i think it's it's
great that
um to see you know parts of the debate
and and even i seen a level of maturity
in the conferences that deal with ai if
you look five years ago um
to now just the amount of workshops and
so on has changed so much is is
impressive to see how much topics of um
you know safety ethics and so on come to
to the surface which is great and if you
were too early clearly it's fine i mean
it's a big field and there's lots of
people um with lots of um interest that
will do progress or make progress um and
obviously i don't believe we're too late
so
in that sense like i think it's great
that we're doing this already
you